[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america christy
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
today number one best-selling author
with her new book out for sale on
pre-sale right now take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance be
sure you check that out at
ramseysolutions.com we're here to talk
to you about your life and your money
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five
two two five jacob is with us hey jacob
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how you doing great man what's
up
not much so i've got a a good problem so
to speak um my wife and i we've been
really good with money ever since we've
been married never really had any debt
other than our house
um i had a good opportunity to make some
good money in the past years at work but
recently i took a promotion which kind
of came to pay cut because of the
overtime and so i'm trying to get our
family locked down on budgeting
and i've had some resistance the past
years my wife and it's not because she's
not great with money but she's a
full-time teacher she's mom four kids
runs our house
and so the problem is she pays for a lot
of our miscellaneous expenses that are
not like mortgage utilities things of
that nature and so i need her input and
her information help make our budget
work but usually every time i need to
get it she's just so busy it becomes a
little bit of a like a tense you know
conflict between us and it just stops so
i don't know if you had any advice on
how to kind of get your wife on board
when she's busy and she's great with
money but it's hard to make a budget
when you can't get her half of what
she's spending and try to figure that
whole thing out
she's not busy
she doesn't she doesn't want you telling
her what to do
this is an excuse go on dave
please she is she is busy but busy is an
excuse she doesn't want you telling her
what to do how much you told me three
times how good she is with money and yet
she doesn't do a budget so she's not
good with money that's also bs how much
pay cut did you take i feel like that
that's coming into play somehow
uh well i worked a ridiculous amount of
overtime in law enforcement and so as
you know the crime rate's been kind of
spiking around the country so i went
from probably the 170 range because of
all the overtime down to about 110.
and
did y'all talk about that extensively
and all the repercussions of that
decision
before it happened
oh absolutely um i was in a very uh
high use area of law enforcement and so
i was gone a lot and we really kind of
realized there was a certain shelf life
with that and so the promotion was the
best way out of that because it came
with a guaranteed pay increase but i
could be home a lot more and not you
know getting burned out so much
yeah
all right cool
well here's the thing and here's the
thing you have been handling all the
money and uh giving her an allowance to
run the household on and she doesn't
want you tinkering in her allowance
so um
the you have to have a bigger vision to
get her to speak into this and the
bigger vision includes her voice counts
her vote counts
she's not going to have things taken
away from her but she is going to hold
herself
accountable
and you both are going to be held
accountable to
the a plan that you put in place to
cause your future to happen
and that is simply we're going to sit
down we're going to sit down and do a
the kids are going to go to bed and
we're going to sit down we're going to
turn off the television and we're going
to have
you know it takes about 45 minutes
a week for the first 90 days and after
that it takes about 20 minutes a week
to keep a budget going so it does not
take that much time
this is about more than time well and
the other thing jacob and i'll tell you
because my husband and i do this
exactly like this we will decide in
advance when we're going to have that
conversation so if he came to me about
anything when i'm in the middle of
putting meals on the table or wrangling
the kids no i'm not that's not a good
time to do that thing because you are
it's all hands on deck when the kids are
up but if you say hey i'd like for us to
work on the budget on sunday night at 8.
does that work for you and she says yes
that works for me or no let's do this
time instead and you literally put it on
the counter okay so i just want to are
we on the same page or sunday night at
eight the kids are down we're gonna
we're gonna get the kitchen cleaned up
we're gonna sit down and work on this
together is that good for you because
i want your input and because i want us
to be in agreement about where our
future's going we've done a good job to
date but with this pay cut i'm really
nervous and i need your help yeah
and you and you plan it plan when you're
going to have that conversation and then
you do so then when sunday night comes
like okay here we go
it's just agreed upon it's not in this
in the moment trying to squeeze in a
major conversation when life can be
chaotic so just put it on the calendar
and again like dave said share the why
of it why does this matter
why and how you value her opinion and
it's going to give a different tone to
it that
that will hopefully make it make it go
better yeah you guys have never agreed
on your spending before
you together
uh you agreed on the mortgage stuff and
that she got x number dollars after that
to run the household in quotes
uh whatever that meant to her and you
didn't care what it meant and so but now
you have to care which is good so you're
going to aim at the future a little bit
more detail
and say we're as a couple we're going to
set the vision
for where we want to be in 10 years and
as a couple we're going to decide
what
we have to do to accomplish that vision
yeah the budget would reflect that and
jacob i mean when you're having this
conversation one other thing i'll throw
in there and we're giving you several
several tips here but
ask her
why she doesn't want to do it i i'm a
direct person sometimes i'm like if i
sense resistance hey seems like you
don't want to do this just tell me why
she's already told her she's too busy i
know that's not true no but keep that's
what i mean keep pressing say no like
sunday night we're not busy or whatever
time hey is it because you feel like i'm
taking money away is it because you feel
like you don't gonna say is it because
you whatever just ask some open-ended
questions and then maybe if you peel
away the layers there the first answer
you might get is she's busy but then
once you keep pressing and and in a
loving way it might be like hey i'm
really scared of what you know what it's
going to look like i'm scared i'm not
going to have money for then you start
to be able to solve things at the root
issue which is actually where they need
to be solved it's not this surface level
busy conversation you actually get to
what's really going on so don't be
afraid to ask some of those direct
questions but ask them in love and then
you might find the real answer so you
can start to work at it at that at that
level now from
30 years of doing this
my suspicion is
is that your
it feels like you're taking away some of
her power yeah because this is an area
that she you know you're like asking to
move into her territory this has been
delegated to her and now you're actually
wanting to know what's going on and she
doesn't like you having a voice in it
um and because she's used to running it
and leave me alone and i haven't done a
bad job and there's no reason well there
is a reason we need to do this together
yeah and make a decision together yeah
and uh it can be some of the biggest
fights you have if you don't get through
that it's a big deal very very very
important so folks when you learn to do
a plan together a spending plan together
that's what rachel calls it because she
likes to spend
a spending plan that's all a budget is
you're telling your money what to do
instead of wondering where it went as a
couple when you are married and you
decide together where you're doing that
you are officially deciding what's
important to you
as a couple
both of you have a say and we join
our values into one and we say as a
couple
we think this is more important than
that
we think
this thing here is a big deal we want to
get both of these done but
this one's going first
and when you start making those
decisions together you create a level of
unity in your relationship that you can
create no other way a budget is unique
in doing that as a
marriage
enhancement
tool
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality
is my co-host number one best-selling
author and author of the new book on
pre-sale now it launches in early
september take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance if
you get it at
ramseysolutions.com in the store you
will find it's a 20 book but it comes
with a hundred dollars plus worth of
goodies
that go with it um all kinds of fun
things happening including a live stream
that she and i are doing on launch week
and all about life balance um and so
she's doing it i'm gonna yak a little
bit and so uh but anyway it's we're
looking forward to this book launch it
is a fabulous book on balancing your
life this whole thing of life balance
has got so many
um
lies out there about it and so much
guilt and shame around the subject and
christie's cut through all of that and
put together this great book
uh so
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money take back your
time as the book the guilt-free guide to
life and the balance all right let's try
uh what 20 minutes say what did you say
laura you said no no phones right now
the phones are dead oh great okay that's
cool all right well let's let's jack
about this then because it's a good
subject and let's talk about the lies
because you're right there's a lot of
guilt and shame on this topic here's
what i found
we don't know what balance is we just
know we don't have it and so we have
this feeling that haunts us that we're
always failing no matter what we do
we're doing the wrong thing and and
that's why i love this subtitle the
guilt-free
guide to life balance because similar to
what we were saying earlier dave in the
conversation about money there's always
the issue below the issue and if we
don't address the deeper issues
that are at play with how we manage our
time then the symptoms are going to keep
creeping up again and again in our
calendar and so i really dig into what's
going on that keeps us
from feeling
like we are doing the right things at
the right time and showing and showing
people what that looks like in a
practical way i was um asking actually
hosting the ramsay show with ken last
week
or um two weeks ago and we were talking
about this and i think it's one of those
things where there's a seasonality to
our life and so whether someone is
starting a new job paying off their debt
baby step number two they have a new
baby you know whatever that looks like
the season you're in will affect
how you spend your time what's right for
you right now and even what your version
of balance looks like i don't think
enough people talk about that they don't
talk enough about the season you're in
and how that affects
what you spend your time on
and you know it occurs to me that
there's
you get tired exhausted physically
you can get exhausted emotionally
you can even get in exhausted
intellectually yeah your brain just
starts to hurt
and um in almost every one of those
types of exhaustion where the fatigue is
you know smothering
it's not because you were busy yeah
it's because you were living in chaos
yeah yeah and you feel felt like that
you were there's this internal thing
pulling at you the whole time you're
busy that you're doing the wrong thing
at the wrong time
and that exhausts you
more thoroughly than just being tired
from working yeah and it can feel when
you're in one of those seasons where you
are tired or exhausted or stressed it
can feel like it's going to last forever
and it doesn't and so even remembering
this is the season a season of getting
out of debt a season of little kids a
season of whatever it won't last forever
it gives you a new level of strength
and even more of an objective
perspective to be able to get through
that season because you know it's not
going to last forever this is not a
forever thing maybe you're in a tough
time but this is not forever and so i
want to help people identify their
season they're in
figure out what life balance looks like
in that season for them and then show
them how they can get through it in
practical ways yeah it is not about
doing
necessarily doing less of something it's
about doing the right thing at the right
time on purpose yeah you can feel
balanced and still be busy and i'm busy
i'm i'm super busy but i'm doing the
right things and so even though yes of
course at the end of the days i'm tired
but i'm energized from doing the right
things it's not that kind of tired of oh
man i feel all this guilt because i'm
doing the wrong things it's once you
begin to align your time with what's
most important to you what you actually
care about those things are life-giving
to you and it gives you energy um to get
through it makes you feel more balanced
it also makes you have more fun because
you're doing the right things
the book is take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance at
ramseysolutions.com in the store
danielle is in santa cruz california hi
danielle how are you
hi dave hi chrissy how are you guys hey
great how can we help
awesome um okay so
um let's see um we have been debt free
since january thank you for that
um
i just have a quick question about
retirement stuff we have a fully funded
emergency fund um my husband cashed out
his retirement a couple years ago this
was before you
um and so we ought like we know now it
was a huge mistake and so um i have some
retirement saved up from a job that i
had before we got married and so um he's
like seven or eight years older than i
am and so i'm wondering if um we should
front load his iras 401ks all of that
stuff and kind of let him catch up to me
because he's going to reach 59 and a
half
probably seven years before i will
by front load you mean out of your baby
step four or your 15
yes sir
okay
so out of if you're putting 15 into
retirement you're just saying put more
of it in his name
because he's going to hit 59 and he can
access it
yes and i already have um about 16 000
in my retirement so he and he has about
a thousand
how old are you guys
uh i'm 26 and he's 32.
it doesn't matter
okay
you have 30 freaking years
you're going to be okay
yeah doesn't matter just put 15 in the
right place
don't worry about this lord i thought
you were like 50 and he was 62 or
something
no i didn't think you were that old i
just couldn't figure out the question
lent itself to that
so um you are you are the master planner
girl i mean you're playing way out
that's awesome that's going to bode well
for you but you're uh my point is i
think you're overthinking it a little at
this stage so i think you'll be just
fine to do the right thing get the best
you know get the best match whoever has
that that's number one then number two
get as much roth as you can get uh and
then who has the best selection of
mutual funds and both of you have a roth
with mutual funds up to 15 of your
income in your baby step four i assume
you're at baby step four and you know
what that means
yes yep
okay yeah that's and that's where this
question stemmed from but yeah you're
you've got enough time you're gonna be
okay yeah i'm with you whenever she was
asking us thinking like this was any
minute like he might retire like in a
few years so we're trying to like speed
this up but yeah you got you got plenty
of time you're you're getting started
way earlier than most danielle so well
done yeah absolutely so if let's say
let's change the question to what i
thought it was okay someone that's older
because somebody's uh let's say she's
uh 40
and he's
uh 53
that's where i kind of thought we were
okay so he's got like five years six
years before he can access this and if
we put a bunch in his name even
if they were a little less performing
mutual fund or maybe maybe it wasn't a
roth and we would rather have a roth
that kind of thing at least we got some
in his name because it's going to be
several years before she catches up yeah
but if she had
300 000 in her account and he had almost
none in his account um and there was
that kind of and you were that close to
this yeah i might then say
let's let's do that but she's got enough
time it's all going to work out yeah
yeah yeah
melanie is with us in canada hi melanie
welcome to the ramsay show
hi there dave and christy how are you hi
great what's going on
great um i have a question i'm on baby
step 2 right now i'm 77 000 i'm working
away at it
my so i've got a second job i'm trying
to throw as much money as my debt as i
can but my eldest son he's 18 he's
destined for university but
he's doing one more extra year of high
school that buys me a little bit of time
he's unable to work he's sick
um but i have enough money to fund
completely his first year university but
my plan always before you was um just to
like feed and house them kind of deal
they would have to pay for their tuition
well now obviously that can't happen so
i don't know if i should be throwing my
money at my debt is it he's so sick he
can't work but he can go to university
oh no no we're hoping we're hoping
there's a hope so i'm just trying to
plan for when he gets to be able to go
yeah
uh
i don't know i don't know i would have
to think through this really hard before
i put his
paying for his school ahead of you
getting out of debt i think he's got to
work this out and you got to help him
work it out i'm with you on that
scholarships grants other other options
too maybe let's be real careful here
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage justin and kelsey are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you welcome where do y'all live uh
kenosha wisconsin all right well welcome
to nashville and here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
146 000. wow
how long did this take 26 months
and your range of income during that
time we started at 125 and we ended at
146. excellent what do you guys do for a
living
so i work in the business operations
department for a large recreation
facility
and i run a business analytic business
analytics uh
department cool awesome well welcome
guys what kind of debt was the 146
thousand
it was pretty much everything credit
cards student loans uh vehicles medical
bills cell phones a mattress we're
normal people
just great americans
pretty much
i love it way to go guys
so how long you guys have been married
uh nine months nine months oh
so you started working on this before
marriage during uh
during engagement period i guess all
right so tell us the story how did this
go down uh well we uh we had some good
encouragement uh my my now mother-in-law
was at the tail end of her uh debt-free
journey following the baby steps and uh
so we decided to sit down uh and
you know put this on paper and actually
look at everything and our goal was uh
to try to finish this uh before being
married knowing that when we become
married we're going to want to know all
these things and obviously be on the
same page so
it took us a little longer than we
wanted um but you know we still got to
the end of the end of the road there
yeah 26 months is not bad yeah not bad
at all so who had the most of the debt
it was it was pretty even uh to be
honest uh okay pretty even split i think
when we sat down we just kind of
you know we knew going into the
relationship we both had debt um and we
just kind of sat down and put all out
there there was no judgement it was kind
of like this is what i have this is what
you have
and we just wanted to be upfront about
that before we even got married and you
know
well good for you that's impressive that
you guys were so receptive to it because
a lot of people when someone a loving
family member for example comes to them
and says hey
like your mother you need some help
people dig their heels in so what was
that what was that like was it the total
money makeover book did you listen to
the podcast like how how did you guys
get get in line with the plan and the
baby steps and all that yeah so i think
um i'm
like justin said my mom was at the tail
end of uh baby step two when we started
and i think we kind of just were living
like normal people and then we saw all
the success that we had and we realized
there was you know more to life than
just paying other people we kind of joke
because uh we probably were putting 40
to 50 percent of our take-home pay
towards debt every month yeah and we're
like yeah we can go on like a week-long
vacation every month because you know
the money that we're paying towards
other people um we just you know
realized there was more and we didn't
want to work forever so you know we're
like let's just you know tackle this now
um and we're still young and have a
better future good for you how old are
you
i am 28. 32. where'd it go awesome very
cool
so i mean you tackle one of life's
biggest subjects while you're engaged
going into your marriage and finish it
up in the first year of your marriage uh
that's a that's a big deal
from a relationship standpoint it sets
you on a really solid foundation to do
anything you want to do now from a math
standpoint you're free to be able to do
anything you want to do that's very very
impressive and just to be on the same
page with your values like the fact that
you you both were all in from the
beginning that's huge so many couples
try to get on the same page in order to
work the plan where it's once i can i
get my spouse on board and you guys are
both just like yeah let's do it so what
what a great foundation to start your
marriage on really turned our tables
when we were
we sat everything we sat down and put
everything on and then we were planning
the wedding and uh unfortunately cove
had turned our our dream wedding into a
not dream wedding so we uh we had a
pivot in a lot of that but because of
the road we were on it made those
decisions easier on
having to you know pull back on what we
wanted to do for our wedding yeah and
then and put some other things in place
it was not as much worry and risk
anymore because we were really close to
the end so good for you yeah that's cool
very good guys all right now what's the
big deal when people say
how do you pay off 146 000 in 26 months
making 140 what do you tell them
i think it's really the budget for
myself
putting it on paper seeing it and
actually seeing it come in and come out
as you usually allude to it's you're
putting it out there to show
um what you're able to do and give
yourself permission so
getting it on paper and visibility i
think would be my my big thing yeah
justin's kind of the nerdy spreadsheet
guy no the data guy yeah the data guy no
way yeah so he he made the budget we
obviously had our budget meetings um i
think justin hit the nail on the head uh
it was kind of crazy for us to actually
sit down and look at the budget and
realize we're spending x amount of money
going out to eat and x amount of money
on you know random amazon purchases that
we don't need and it's like wow you know
why are we spending all this money on
things that you know don't really matter
when we could be putting the set or dead
and um yeah i think the big key is just
following the budget um i know you lose
to that all the time but it i personally
think that is the key following the
budget you know making sure you're you
know staying on track with all that
stuff well it's so interesting you guys
say that because it's we can say it all
day but hearing from people that have
actually followed the budget and gotten
debt free is is so powerful and you know
on youtube they were just showing
y'all's tracker system it's so
fascinating because research shows that
nothing is more motivating
than seeing progress and so when you
guys begin to track it with your you
know a lot of people have visual charts
and you've got your budget and that type
of thing you see that progress it
motivates you to want to make more
progress and that's what helps you stick
with it it's the reason one of the
reasons we tell people to pay off your
debts smallest to largest by balance is
to feel those quick wins and that
progress and you guys did that well done
you all are awesome that was kind of the
nice thing when we started is we had you
know several credit cards you know 1500
2000 our mattress was 1200 phones we
paid all that stuff off very quickly and
at least for me it gave me a lot of
motivation you know then we got to the
student loans which was you know 20 000
or 30 000 and you know when you get to
those big numbers it's almost like we're
never going to get done and then
you know you did it right all of a
sudden there you are yeah
right wow that's amazing
very very cool so obviously mom was
cheering you on outside of the two of
you who else were your cheerleaders
i'd say kind of um everybody kind of was
secretly cheering us on but i don't know
if it was
i would say it was sincere but i think
they kind of thought we were goofballs
for doing this until the end and then
now you know we getting we're getting
friends and family and random people
that we've never even met asking us for
advice like how do you do it that's
right you know i posted a thing on
facebook and i had several people
message me like wow you know that's
awesome and what kind of advice do you
have and i want to also get that free
and
for me it was it was kind of cool to see
that just because when we first started
you know we obviously had close family
that were cheering us on but it was
friends and acquaintances and that kind
of stuff that kind of just
you know thought it was cool but you
know they're like oh yeah we've tried
that several times and it didn't work
and it's good for you because it doesn't
work exactly good all that crap yeah
good luck and you know whatever so i
always have an opinion but yeah but it's
this passive aggressive answer yeah
right well way to go guys excellent job
how's it feel now that you're free
it's great
it doesn't feel real yet i mean i think
we made our last payment in
june yeah so um
doesn't feel real totally yet because
we're still working on um our emergency
fund so i feel like once that's done
it'll really feel real like you know
look at all this money and we can start
investing and doing all that stuff so uh
justin already sees the margin in the
budget he knows
it's real he knows the numbers that's
you that's huge well done he's got a
spreadsheet for it too
full software package he wrote actually
but probably yeah well done guys we got
a copy of the legacy journey for you
because that's the next chapter in your
story to continue changing your entire
legacy and of course a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give to
somebody who's asking you about this and
you go this is how you do it these are
the seven baby steps right here in the
total money makeover so the very cool so
congratulations we're so proud of y'all
are heroes well done thank you start off
your life right justin and kelsey from
kenosha wisconsin they paid off
146 000 in 26 months making 125 to 146.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
well done you guys well done
well we get a lot of uh people in their
50s and 60s doing this but i
i think we can all say that when we see
a young couple getting married there's
so much runway in front of them so much
future in front of them all the stuff
they're going to be able to do that's
inspiring that's right sure is yeah
that's amazing very cool so for those of
you that think all millennials are
deadbeats
you're wrong we get to see the bright
stars of the millennial generation they
show up on the debt-free stage every day
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today her new book is take back your
time
the guilt-free guide to life balance if
you feel busy or overwhelmed or never
have enough time to do the things you
want to do doesn't have to be that way
at the take back your time event on
thursday september the 16th you're gonna
learn how to take back your time the
guilt way and christie and i'll be
talking to you and walk you you'll walk
away knowing what balance really looks
like passes start at just twenty dollars
and with your event pass you'll also get
over sixty dollars in free bonus items
including a copy of the new book take
back your time you can join us in
nashville for the event and a special
book signing with christy or you can
join via the live stream either way you
guys can feel balanced even in your busy
life so text time
to 33 789 we'll get you signed up for
all that time
two three three
seven
eight nine
charles is with us in austin texas hi
charles welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um so
i've
i'm debt-free um i do i have about three
million dollars and i'm curious if
that's enough
to comfortably retire
it should be
it's a lot of money well done
thank you how old are you
58 okay
well we have to define uh comfortably
and we have to define uh what you're
gonna do with this money because
obviously you're not stupid or you
wouldn't have ended up with three
million dollars but if you suddenly grew
stupid uh you could get rid of the three
million real quickly and not retire
right
correct so you know if you're but if you
had it reasonably invested and lived on
that income obviously you could retire
so if it were me i would have put that
in good growth stock mutual funds making
11 or 12 percent and lived off of about
10 or less which means i would have
somewhere around 250 300 000 a year to
live on i think i could struggle through
and the money would never and then the
principal would never deplete
substantially during that time and i
could do that in perpetuation if you can
do that then you're going to be just
fine if you want to put it in cds and
make two percent well you're gonna have
to live on very little while you're
through while your three million dollars
sits there and deteriorates in its uh
purchasing power
right i put i put about two million into
the market
and then i kept like a million off to
the side just in case everything goes to
heck and back you know i can either you
know add to it
or you know leave that towards
uh you know other investments in real
estate because i that's how i made my
money was real estate i'd probably put
it in real estate then
okay instead of sidelining a million
dollars because let's just say a million
dollars makes ten percent that's a
hundred thousand dollars a year you're
losing sidelining it
right so i wouldn't want to sideline a
hundred grand um i'm a sideline some of
it but i feel like you know if one of
the things goes really badly i think the
other one's probably going to be okay
and generally speaking i would say real
estate is a
a less risky investment overall but
you're a real estate guy would you agree
with that charles
yeah yeah i i absolutely would but it's
also you know it it takes a lot of your
time and a lot of your effort yes and
that's extra hassle for just exited yeah
yes yes there's all there's there's a
lot that goes into it you know yeah i
owned you know i've done flips i've done
you know i sold an apartment building
that's one of my main things i'm in wow
um but if you were managing it yourself
it was a super high hassle but if you if
you outsource the management or or hired
somebody to manage it for you under your
direction
either one yeah you'd be fine so it all
comes down to the answer to your
question is can i retire on three
million dollars
yes if you invest it
and live off of the what the investment
creates without touching the three
million you're ready
okay
okay great job
so what do you need of your living thank
you
uh you know i mean we've been living the
whole time on like 50 to 60. okay um
you know the entire time while building
building this well 100 100 000
is what is that is that 3 on 3 million
yeah
yeah
so surely to god son you can do that
yeah yeah as long as everything doesn't
come crashing down i'm not you know i
haven't been in the market a long time
i've never if everything comes crashing
down to the point that you're only
making three percent on your investments
we got bigger problems than three
million dollars are going to solve
that's true
true well i've got two kids though too
that i gotta put through college and pay
for weddings and
all that kind of thing
so that's that's kind of my
you know
intrepidation of unless you're dropping
a million dollars on this stuff that
doesn't even matter
okay
i mean what are you going to spend on
all that you know i mean you should be
able to
again you should you should make this
money create eight or ten percent and
you got a 300 000 year income to do
something with if you live out of 100
and spend the rest of it on your kids i
mean you're still gonna be okay yeah i
think you just need to plan for it it
feels like i hear a lot of unknowns in
your voice and there's a couple unknowns
like whatever you decide to spend on
these weddings or college just put a
number to it put it on paper talk to
your kids about whatever that plan looks
like
and then all the other unknowns of like
if the market crashes and all that
that's just fear that's just i mean we
could sit here and run one if what if
scenarios all day but we're gonna go
based on facts and the fact is you've
got three million which is enough to
live on and pay for weddings and
colleges and you just stand on that you
stand on the truth of those numbers make
a plan for the numbers and then let that
give you the confidence that that you
need versus running these doomsday
scenarios because you're in a great
position
so um wait a minute i got to stay with
this a second because this is okay how
old are you
58. you told me that okay so you did
real estate deals for how many years
uh gosh since i bought my first house
when i was 22. okay and so
yeah so we're about the same age and
about the same deal okay except i went
broke in between but um
but the uh
the the point is
the point is you need to get some real
estate stuff going
because you have a much more high you
have a much higher comfort uh zone
comfort level with real estate than you
do the stock market because you know it
you've got 40 years worth of knowing
and you know it inside now you you're
not gonna fret
if you've got some of this money
invested in real estate and you need to
pick some real estate that's not as high
hassle factor the highest hassle factor
in the world is a freaking apartment
complex buy something where they just
send you checks it's commercial real
estate i like i've got i've got a
a couple of retail centers and i've got
a couple of office buildings
and they they bring me almost no drama
i got five houses that bring me more
drama than all the other freaking
hundred million dollars worth of stuff
put together you know so you can you can
go just go get some low drama real
estate and that's going to give you let
you calm down that's a really good
insight that's a really good point you
know because he knows that he's
spreading as he moved everything from
what he knows to somebody doesn't know
yeah that's a really good insight that's
good jesus is with us in philadelphia hi
jesus what's up
hi dave i just wanted to start off with
saying it's an honor to finally speak to
you i've been listening to you since i
was in seventh grade
um and
yeah are you in eighth grade
i actually just graduated college last
week congratulations congratulations
wow i'm honored what's your degree in
uh business and i work in accounting
cool cool i'm a little short on time
what's your question
all right so basically i just moved from
miami to philadelphia for a job
opportunity last week and i currently
have
ten thousand dollars in credit card debt
and i'm trying to get out of that invest
in my future and be financially free and
i don't know where to start
you've been listening since seventh
grade and you don't know where to start
yes i know what i mean dave you need to
do a better job
no
christy just said it
dave you are obviously not being very
clear with the baby steps
no no you are definitely i just made i
stopped listening to you last year and
look what happened
that's what it is there it is that's it
you fell off the wagon jesus so um all
right i'm gonna send you a graduation
gift and now that you're grown up you're
gonna read the total money makeover with
a different set of eyes and it's gonna
show you the baby steps again hey susan
then you're gonna remember oh i remember
when i heard that kid
he used to tell people to do that stuff
so yeah you're gonna know exactly what
to do it's gonna come back to you
quickly the total money makeover has
shown eight million people how to work
this clear path and and now jesus is on
the list so hold on we'll give you a
graduation gift
maybe the book will do a better job than
i did christy
shut up christy just shut up
how we're gonna wrap up this hour is
with a strong shut up
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality is my co-host today number
one best-selling author and author of
the brand new book that is on pre-sale
right now we launch it in early
september but you can get a copy now
take back your time
the guilt free guide
to life balance
actually i should say you can buy a copy
now we'll ship it to you in september
when the actual pub date is but why
would you do that why would you buy a 20
book a month early or
i don't know three weeks early because
we're gonna give you a hundred plus
dollars worth of extra goodies for
buying it the e-book the audiobook a
ticket to a live stream all kinds of
good stuff so check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com
sami is with us sammy's in fort worth
texas hi sammy how are you
i'm fine thank you and i appreciate you
taking my call sure what's up uh well i
am a recent widow my husband passed away
in march i'm 71.
we owned our own home um
i
i have thirty six thousand dollars in
debt i have thirty thousand dollars in
the bank
and i am
i'm debating about whether to pay part
of my debt off or hang on to the thirty
thousand dollars because it gives me so
much of a security to feel to know it's
there i can make the payments that i
have and i am paying additional
to get things paid off but i just am
wanting to make sure i'm making the
proper
uh decisions it makes me nervous to
think about not having that money there
if i needed it yeah i'm sorry you've
been through a hard time how long were
you guys married
83 years my goodness
he the last six months he's been in the
memory care
[Music]
and of course a lot of our money went to
that sure sure
but we had it i'm thankful we had it to
do it
yeah
but this is what's left of your nest egg
yes sir you don't have any money
you don't have any money other than what
you told me
no
uh he didn't have life insurance he
spent a lot of time in the military and
had a really nice life insurance knowing
they kept saying you can roll us over
when you retire but when he retired it
was so expensive we couldn't afford it
[Music]
they didn't tell us that part yeah
so what is your income based on social
security and what else i get his social
security i get
money from his va and i get a little bit
from his retirement at the end at the
beginning of next year my income will go
from
3 400 a month to 38 and then the
following year we should go to 4 000.
providing our government is still able
to pay it
well and i do have a small part-time job
but it's not a very it's not a
high-paying job i'm using that money to
go ahead and pay off on
uh my other stuff to try to i've only
got two other bills and i'm trying to
get those paid off yeah
well number one i don't think you need
to worry about getting uh the money from
the government it will come
one of the least politically uh
uh palatable things uh one of the things
that pissed people off the most is not
taking care of widows of veterans okay
so
um that would be uh that would be like a
a good way to never get elected again
you know so
um you're not going to have that problem
that's that money's going to come
so basically we got 3 500 to 4 000 a
month to live on and that's your game
plan for retirement and what is the 36
000 in debt on
uh i have a car that
we bought a couple years before he
passed away we would have had our others
paid other one paid off but he was
having trouble getting in and out of our
pickup
and we were i was expecting to have him
for a much longer time and i we bought a
van that we could fix a ramp and put a
wheelchair in
with the understanding that we thought
he would be here for a long time
and then that didn't happen
and i'm i'm a little bit emotionally
attached to it but that doesn't mean i
couldn't sell it i didn't what do you
want transportation what are you on i
owe 29 000. is it uh wheelchair equipped
now or it was just for you
no it's not it's not we just
were
looking forward to that possibility do
you have another vehicle in the driveway
no
that's your only vehicle that's the only
one and i do have to drive four and a
half miles four and a half hours to see
a friend and another son in new york
who's in the military
so i need a good vehicle i don't have to
have i can rent a car to do that
oh okay
can you rent cars today yeah well
they're hard it can be done but what
i've heard but you don't need to keep a
29 000 car for two trips a year
um when your income is only thirty six
thousand dollars thirty four thousand
thirty five thousand dollars so this
car's gotta go hon
okay i know you're emotionally attached
to it but it's killing you
yeah
if you didn't have the weight of that
your picture changes pretty dramatically
would you agree yeah
yes and i can make it on what i have i'm
not making a lot of headway but here's
here's the you don't have much wiggle
room huh and the other thing sammy that
that um that savings that you have that
gives you that peace of mind you'll be
able to keep some of that if you get rid
of this car if you don't get rid of the
car then that savings gonna have to go
to your debt so look at this not at what
you're giving up but what you're getting
to keep you're getting to keep
a lot of your savings because you're
going to change your plan
with your vehicle are you a member of a
good church
yes okay
get some of that and get some of the
guys in the church to help you find a
really quality five thousand seven
thousand dollar car
pay cash for it okay pay cash for it and
get rid of the van
okay i do
my van is worth more than i owe on it at
least or at least it was a month ago
good okay
and um
yeah and you knew this deep down your
heart it just required me to be the mean
guy to say it out loud right yeah i was
just having a hard time with it i
understand donna of course you are of
course you are
you just lost your husband of course you
are and you know and i hope you don't
think i'm heartless i'm actually trying
to help
i understand okay this is still really
new too sammy i mean we're talking a few
months ago yeah yeah it's it's been
harder i mean i knew it was coming yeah
it has been harder than i thought it
would be
because i've been expecting it well i
mean anyway 53 years worth of getting
used to somebody i mean my gosh
it's hard yeah i tell you it is hard and
it doesn't
and it gets it's gotten harder recently
than it
i don't know how to explain that but
you kind of had to take care of business
for a little while once you kind of got
all the business taken care of now you
now you can kind of relax oh wait a
minute there's the grief the reality
sets in yeah
yeah
i'm sorry
and bless his heart he
because of the disease he had and the
medications he was on we had a pretty
good income but he didn't understand
saving he
part of his deal was it caused uh him to
go spend money although he didn't get us
in debt in a point that we couldn't
handle it it was just that it was
difficult yeah
tell you what we're going to do i want
you to go through financial peace
university that'll put some community in
your life some people around you we're
going to walk you through a detailed
class on exactly how to handle money i
think you're pretty sharp i think you
can probably pull it off by yourself but
i want to make sure we're there with you
and walking with you while you go
through this time okay
so you hang on laura's going to pick up
and we'll get you signed up for
financial peace as our gift gift to you
we're going to take care of widows
always here and
you call me back anytime you need help
honey you're going to make it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to puretalk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70
a month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well i know it snuck up on you but it's
august matter of fact it's the middle of
august and
we've noticed that once everyone gets
done with the distractions of summer the
kids are back in school things kind of
kick into high gear
you got some goals you want to reach you
notice the christmases in december this
year
and i got to get ready for it and fall
is the second new year in a sense
to help you get back on track we're
running great and new deals every week
at ramsey ramseysolutions.com
starting our only ten dollars and today
only our team is marking down the number
one bundle the starter special to only
39.99 that's the lowest we've ever done
on the starter special if you're brand
new it's a good place to get in
it's 76 off you get all the books tools
and a new money assessment
to help you get back on track check it
all out at ramseysolutions.com
we've also got ken coleman's book there
from paycheck to purpose on pre-sale
we've got christy wright's new book
on pre-sale take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance and
we've got a 500 cash giveaway every week
this month with a grand prize of three
thousand dollars cash at the end of
august of course no purchase necessary
of course you must be 18
or older to win check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com or you can text cash
to 33
789 text cash 233
789 mark's in atlanta hi mark welcome to
the ramsey show
how are you great man what's up
um
i'm i'm 57 and i feel like i'm very
close to being able to retire
and i've
got all the kids there's college and all
the other stuff houses paid off all that
good all those good things
the the thing that i'm interested in
between now and the time i'm 65 is
health insurance and i've looked at
i've got cobra i can take for 18 months
if i leave
and then i've looked at the sharing
programs like i'm at a share but
i was wanting to see if there was
anything y'all knew of that i've missed
that
may be a good answer
well it depends on the type of coverage
and what coverage you're wanting those
are the two things i would have looked
at too and also i would just look at uh
an independent insurance
agent and let them shop and see what
kind of health insurance they could get
for you blue cross blue shield or or who
else is out there writing in georgia
that's uh doing a good job just as an
individual policy they're not uh i mean
if you take a high deductible hsa
they're usually not outlandish
right have you got have you saved some
money i mean if you're retiring awfully
young so i'm guessing you built some
nest egg yes sir yeah we have
uh my wife and i have been pretty
diligent about it so uh
what's your nest egg
it's right at two
um
two what million
way to go
well thank you very much we've been
blessed
you're a hero man did you start from
nothing
uh pretty much you inherit this money
no sir so you're an everyday millionaire
you did it yourself
way to go dude
excellent job
well i think you're going to be fine
it's just a frustration
you got the money to buy you got the
money to buy the health insurance and
you just got to shop around and between
the sharing programs you can look at
those you can look at your cobra you
probably can beat cobra in the open
market depending on how unreasonable
your pre your coverage is from your old
company right
well yeah i think if you just go to dave
or go to ramsey solutions and click on
the health insurance elps uh the ramsey
trusted elps get an independent
insurance agent that'll shop the
different companies and find you best
the best options out there and put them
in front of you but i think a high
deductible i mean you could you could
afford a ridiculous deductible but only
if only that's only necessary if you
uh got a deal for it but i mean if you
pick up a five or five or even a seven
thousand dollar hsa deductible that's no
big problem at
all okay you can handle you can handle
those problems it's the 150 000 bypass
that you don't want to
ensure yourself insure through right
that's right
amen
so
amen yeah that's the thing thank you hey
thank you man congratulations i'm proud
of you yeah well done
health insurance is scary and when you
get 65 medicare will
make you wish you earned enough money to
not have to depend on the government
it's so freaking confusing
and it is an absolute nightmare and the
coverages oh my gosh it's a problem
so this whole health insurance issue is
a discussion all the time
michael is with us in lincoln nebraska
hey michael welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey so
we uh we put an offer in on a house
and um it was contingent upon us getting
the financing
and we
were
i don't know i guess we thought that our
house would sell in like
24 hours and we thought we were going to
get you know at least asking price or
that would maybe even escalate
and then several weeks later um
we're getting ready to get to the
closing date here and we haven't even
had one offer on our house i mean we've
had
several price reductions we just can't
quite figure out what's going on
we put some money down as an earnest
deposit
and i guess we're just completely lost
on what do we do from here because
they're recommending a bridge loan and i
really don't want to do a bridge loan
and they're telling us yeah you know
you're going to get approved and it's
like well i don't necessarily want to be
approved because it's going to be
way more than what we were expecting to
pay so i guess
we're just kind of looking for some
advice on on where we go from here we
wish we would have sold the house
before i know i've listened to your
shows and that's what you would
recommend and i didn't even i didn't
hear that piece of the advice but so
anyway we're just kind of
wondering what we do from here and how
you would how you would process this
situation
have you talked to your agent about why
it's not selling i know you said you've
done some price reductions but i mean
has they shot you straight of what they
think it is
you know for like the first two weeks
we didn't really get a lot of feedback
uh we're hearing maybe it's the
neighborhood i mean it's not the nicest
part
um
we no we haven't really gotten like
tremendous feedback the neighborhood is
really pretty much the only thing we've
heard or it's been people who are just
kind of coming in kicking tires not
serious about looking you know
first-time home buyers i mean we've had
a decent amount of traffic we've had
several home showings a couple of them
were bus but oh really we've just heard
maybe the neighborhood we you know we've
we've looked at the comps several times
we we think it's priced accordingly and
you know we've had a seven percent
reduction
and even after all the reductions we're
just we're still not getting any
any feedback is it ugly
i mean i mean
let's have a moment like we're trying to
shoot you straight here michael like
what like is it right
i mean
no i don't think everyone who's looked
at it and that's i've tried to get tons
of third-party advice like i'm just i'm
asking people like please just like
shoot me straight i agree with you i'm
like you know like we we rep we
repainted inside when we lived there we
repainted the outside i mean what uh
what's it on the morning before
it was on the market for 225 initially
and now it's on the market for what
209
five okay
um
all right and um the other house you
paid
what for
what'd you pay for it uh we we offered
4.75 and it's not contingent upon the
sale of your home
no
so you have given someone your word to
buy that house
yeah so you'll be closing that's where
i'm at you'll be closing on that house
because you gave your word
right
that's the only thing i was that i was
kind of thinking was it is contingent
upon financing but you're right if your
financing doesn't go through
then if they tell you if they turn you
down for the loan due to the fact how
much do you owe on your current home
uh 94.
okay
so the bridge loan would be for your
equity that that's what they're
discussing then
yeah do you have any money for the down
payment if you don't sell your house or
take out a bridge loan
um
our emergency fund yeah then you can you
can close on the deals legally so that's
probably what you're gonna end up doing
okay ask your real estate agent i think
you may need a new real estate agent get
get with our endorsed local providers
and ask them what the average days on
the market is and what the average price
range is
i got a feeling it's a 195 sale price
i think you're price tag
when you think a seven percent price
reduction is a big price reduction
uh that you know it's not a big price
reduction
so
i i think you're about to sell this
house cheap because you did a deal
poorly that's what it sounds like to me
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the new book on pre-sale take back your
time
the guilt-free guide to life balance is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five jay and latoya are on the
line in fort worth texas says on my
screen you guys are debt-free
congratulations
thank you
way to go guys how much have you paid
off
we paid off 194 000 in about four years
right yeah
that's amazing was your range of income
during that time
when we started we were about at 120 and
when we ended we're above 450. what
what do you guys do we're gonna need an
explanation there go on all right i'm
i'm an i.t engineer working in cloud and
uh i'm an accountant and i have my own
firm okay
so both of your careers just exploded
yep absolutely
i mean both of you are making a couple
of hundred man that's pretty incredible
yes wow um we we hustled and bustled and
did everything that we could to you know
get our income up and um it worked you
just got to stay on it and keep grinding
well you picked two good career fields
and you believed you went got educated
and you went and did it man i'm so proud
of y'all
thank you thank you so much what kind of
debt was the 194 thousand
oh it was everything we had student
loans credit cards hospital bills car
loans uh probably older stray cat and
dog too
i love it how long you all been married
17 years we just celebrated in june oh
wow okay very cool awesome so what
happened four years ago after 13 years
of marriage something like uh oh
got to change yeah well we we discovered
you a long time ago and we weren't
gazelle intense as you say we were just
playing around fiddling around still
getting in and out of debt and credit
cards and then once we start making you
know
the income we were at 120 and i was
thinking we make way too much money to
have uh this debt just lying around like
a pet so let's just get rid of it we got
intense and i just couldn't stand
another payment of anything i was just
like sick of it i see a bill in the mail
i hated going to the mailbox i was like
well i don't want to take this trip in
hot texas weather to the mailbox to get
a bill and owe somebody i was sick of it
yeah sick and tired of being sick and
tired you had to get mad to do something
about it no one no one does anything
about it when they're just okay with it
you had to get mad about it yeah you got
to be upset
so latoya jay got sick of walking to the
mailbox
what did you say
uh for me it was you know me being a
number cruncher i just got tired of
seeing negatives
i mean that's valid
we need to get into black
no more parentheses
[Laughter]
i like it it's good the numbers don't
lie that's a good motto right there
no more walks to the mailbox no more
parentheses i'm done with this oh man
this is great you guys are fun this is
cool okay so you you knew about our
stuff but then you kind of had this uh
disgust well up and you said we're sick
and tired and then what did you do from
there
um from there the first thing i did was
we said we're not getting any more car
loans we're not signing up for any more
credit cards and we just made a list
from smallest to biggest and we just
started knocking things out every month
we would just pay something i would take
any gig that i could get in i.t i would
get um
any side job that i could and we just
just kept peeing and kept paying and
kept paying and eventually we're like
we're all done yeah wow
okay
and so you uh
just plug back into us how just the
podcast or the radio station or what no
we i was always an avid listener listen
almost every day if not every other day
and i kept hearing other people over the
years i'm debt free i'm debt free i was
like one day that's gonna be me but i
wasn't mad enough until we got mad and
then we
uh we made it happen yeah that's cool
well congratulations who who uh was your
biggest cheerleaders outside the two of
you
our kids our girls
because they they know you they're like
we want to be on the dead free screen
too
all right
i'm glad they're here that's good very
good
well that proves that you changed your
whole family tree with this and yes that
was definitely the goal we wanted to uh
change the family tree for sure when it
came to fun came to finances be a real
dead gun shame to me making 450 thousand
a year and be broke
it would be a mess i'm so glad you guys
got control of this so very well done
all right so if somebody's listening
what do you tell them the key to getting
out of debt is
um the number one key is to get
organized you take control of your money
and put a name on every single dollar
where it's going no
know where your money is going don't
just
think it's going to happen you have to
get a purpose about your money and just
be intentional about it yeah it's good
that budget telling it where to go
instead of wondering where it went it
makes all the difference
absolutely
proud of you guys your heroes well done
thank you so much very well done we've
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's definitely the next chapter in
your story you've changed your life
you've changed your family tree um i
mean i bet if you look back down your
family tree it's
not nobody making 450 and nobody debt
free right
yeah
absolutely no
well that would be true in most of our
family trees my son i'm just saying wow
very impressive
very impressive you guys very well done
we've also got a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and help
somebody get started uh maybe they can
uh get a clue and get the inspiration
off of you guys because you're inspiring
for sure absolute rock stars well done
well done jay and latoya
fort worth texas
194 000 paid off in four years making
120 to 450 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's america's next generation of
millionaires right there that is so cool
baby steps millionaires you know what i
love that they said he was talking about
how they had listened for years and they
were just kind of playing around
and i just thought man how often we hear
people there's a moment where they
decide to get serious get gazelle
intense
and do something different and that's
what leads to the debt-free scream we've
never had a single person that i know of
call in and say yeah i was just playing
around and then one day i was debt free
no that doesn't happen when you're just
playing around when you're just
listening when you're just being passive
when you're doing the same things you're
going to get the same results it takes
you doing something different something
different getting serious for a short
period of time
that's what leads to the change that's
what leads to the outcome that's what
leads to the debt-free scream i just
love how he acknowledged that there was
a shift he'd been listening he was just
playing around when that shift happened
that's when he got the results he wanted
it's very true and the weird thing is it
doesn't have to be a crisis no no no it
doesn't have to be an external force i
lost my job and that woke me up or i
went through a divorce and that woke me
up it might have been in my mind i was
in a car wreck and that woke me up
you know in his case i just woke up he's
okay he's going to not watch the mailbox
anymore i don't know i make too much
money to be broke yeah it suddenly
became disgusted there was a suddenly
moment there but you're exactly right
there's uh you can wander into debt
but you cannot wander out
no one gets out without intentional
movement it's just it has to be a series
of intentional acts and here's the thing
the people that you're listening to
those of you listening to the show and
there's tens of millions of you
that you're listening to that are
successful with this they don't have to
make 450 000 a year that's highly
unusual
i mean almost all of them increase their
income because they increase their
workload for a short period of time
because what they've discovered is that
you do not get out of debt doing the
same crap you've been doing
if you keep doing the same thing over
and over again expect a different result
that's the definition of insanity
you get out of debt by chopping your
lifestyle you get out of that faster
by completely eliminating your life
beans and rice rice and beans scorched
earth you don't need to see the inside
of a dadgum restaurant unless you're
working there
you don't need to talk to me about a
vacation you're freaking broke you say
all the time it's 20 head knowledge 80
behavior if you're just listening to
this show and you've been listening to
it for a decade and you're not getting
different results you've got to change
your behavior
you can't just listen to it you have to
do it it's not automatic
you have to force your you have to
impose your will
on this situation and the deeper you the
more wired up and fired up you are the
deeper you will sacrifice and the faster
you get out stop your dadgum whining
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today author of the new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance it will come out in
three weeks on september the 14th on
september the 16th
uh
pre-order ends by the way on september
13th so you only have three weeks to get
the bargain the bargain is buy the book
for 20 bucks and it includes 100 worth
of
add-ons that are there all kinds of good
stuff with it and on september 16th
uh she and i will be doing a take back
your time guilt-free
live event a live stream uh with your
pass you get 60 worth of free bonus
items which includes a copy of the book
uh or you can join us in nashville for
the actual event and a special book
signing or you can join us via live
stream however you want to do it
get your pass at ramseysolutions.comtime
or you can buy the book there and get
all kinds of goodies with it and so lots
of different ways to get out this
subject and get your balanced life
moving and christy can give you the
instructions to do that and come in
nashville we're gonna do a book signing
it's gonna be fun uh fun fact
september 16th when we're doing this
live event dave i don't even know if you
know this but that is mary grace's
second birthday so it is just real life
life balance people we just we are
managing all the things together
and it's just going to be we're going to
talk about real life like there is we
have a lot of things going on and we're
going to talk about how to manage that
and keep it all going so
how you can do a live event
on your daughter's birthday on a book on
life balance hey this is can't wait to
hear this this is real life i can't wait
to hear your explanation real life and
if you come in so i'm going to sign your
book so that'll be fun that also if
you're in nashville or driving distance
come
come hang out with me and dave it'll be
fun it'll be fun to be here in person if
you're around so you're pretty sure mary
grace is not gonna need counseling as a
result oh no she may make an appearance
she may make an appearance oh i can
imagine this happening too much cuteness
in the building is the problem then
yeah yeah all right rebecca is with us
in atlanta hi rebecca welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave and christy it's an honor to
speak for you
thank you for taking my call sure what's
going on
well i first have to tell you we do dave
ramsey so much in this house that my
eight-year-old son got a splinter pulled
out this past weekend and he yelled i'm
glitter-free
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's kind of similar i mean there's a
little pain involved in the extraction
but when it's out it feels better yeah
yes very true
um we are on the last debt snowball it's
our um it's our vehicle and we have
gotten the payoff letter for it and my
question is my company awarded me 300
shares of an equity award in stock
and when we found you and got that
gazelle intensity going we said okay
we've learned that it's time to let this
go and cash it in
and i guess my more concentrated
question is when do we sell that because
we've been watching the stock prices
and the the loan on the vehicle is about
a little over 29 000 if we let the stock
price go up to about 310 it covers the
whole shebang if we sell it today we
come out of pocket about 6 500 to pay
off this car
well here's the principle
uh and uh the principle is is that i
don't buy stock
and the increase in value of the stock
uh gets you out of debt i've never told
somebody to go buy stock and
as the stock goes up it'll get you out
of debt
um you didn't do that but it ends up
putting you in exactly the same place
so
if i woke up in your shoes i would sell
it today
okay because there is no guarantee it's
going up
and the principles get out of debt as
fast as possible regardless of
of what the variables that play are yeah
so i don't buy stock and wait on it to
go up to get you out of that that's not
it's not a method that we use but but
but speak to the principle here not just
the not just the idea of stock but let's
dave i'd love for you to talk a little
bit about the idea of waiting
for some potential change that would
then would able me to get out of debt
like sometimes we'll get this call of
well i don't want to pay off my student
loans because the government might bail
me out
and the principle that's at play there
is the the problem the thought process
the the idea behind that of waiting for
someone else that may or may not help me
in putting your eggs in that basket
and how dangerous that is it's almost
putting what psychologists call the
locus of control
outside of yourself yeah you're saying
i'm waiting on something else to fix
this where it is my job yeah now she's
not really trying to no no but it made
me think of that it is that kind of
locus of control question though of um
there's something that happens rebecca
and all the rest of us too uh you know
there's something that happens inside of
us
uh
so powerful when we decide
deep down
deep down in the old gut
that
i'm the problem i'm the solution
i'm going to take action
i'm going to fix this
i'm in control of my destiny none of us
are unnaive enough to think we're 100 in
control of our destiny but when you say
the only way this gets fixed if i
freaking fix it yeah this this being my
life yeah the only way my life gets
fixed is for me to take the bull by the
proverbial horns and just go we are
going to do this i'm going to impose my
will
just sheer action
a whole series of actions and not all of
them
necessarily
have to make perfect mathematical sense
the the value of taking action
supersedes the value of the math game
yes and i think that's it i think that's
the thing that so many people miss
because whether it's a scenario like
this one or a scenario like that i'm not
going to pay off my student loans
because of x y z what it does is it
gives us some kind of shallow
justification for not doing anything
right now well i gotta wait because this
this might happen i gotta wait and
what's interesting is then the
underlying effect is we feel like
victims well i mean the stock hasn't
gone up or well the government hasn't
bailed out no no we're telling you
regardless of what anyone else is doing
you're going to control what you can
control and you're going to get out of
debt as fast as you can become a force
of nature and knock a bunch of crap down
and if you go out there and just become
a whirling derby you become a a
tasmanian devil and you're just like wow
you know and you know and you know
you don't have time and you don't even
stop to think about something like she's
talking about and again rebecca's asking
a valid question totally not a shallow
question it's a valid question but the
problem is the math of what we just told
her to do doesn't work yes assuming that
stock goes up and bails her out
she has to do it she could have waited
she might have waited six weeks and the
whole thing would have taken care of
itself and yet we're telling her take
you know six thousand dollars but we
don't know what six thousand dollars is
going to happen with a single stock in a
company it is not predictable well and
there's these things out there called
pandemics and crap you know you cannot
predict what's going to happen and so
what you can predict is what you can do
and when you start just throwing stuff
and trashing and just just tearing up
just causing a holy ruckus in your life
stuff starts getting out of your way
yeah cause it's stuff i mean
things get scared they're like that
one's coming through yes i ain't getting
in the way and it's like you create this
movement in the spirit you create this
movement in your life that that that
supersedes mathematics yeah it's just
momentum is what it is where the freedom
that you're going to experience and the
control that you're going to maintain is
worth more to you
than this potential gain of six thousand
dollars in the scenario or whatever it
is in some other scenario it's just it's
the freedom and the control that you
have control over your destiny you have
control over your outcome the time in
which you become debt-free and so on
that has a value to it that often we
dismiss
in the name of waiting for the
mathematics but but that's why i think
it's so important to explain this
because if you're going to tell someone
to do something that that someone's
going to you know someone's going to be
tweeting you right how many am i on the
math if you do that listen if you did
the math we wouldn't be getting
ourselves in this situation to begin
with
i think i think explanation is needed
and for people to get the why behind the
principle of you taking control right
now today we don't love rudy or rocky
because they
had oh because they had it all figured
out and their technique was perfect we
loved them because their heart was so
big and they busted up into impossible
possible odds with a sheer force of
nature and took it down and that's why
we all stand up and cheer at those
movies
and that's what i'm asking you to become
is that person it changes everything
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author christy wright is my co-host
today open phones at
825-5225 as we take your calls about
your life
and your money emmanuel is in bend
oregon hi emmanuel how are you
great mr ramsay how are you today better
than i deserve what's up
so um i'm 22 years old um born in the
u.s um married
uh thankfully making uh about 80 grand a
year including bonuses
uh the question oh i am on babysit 3b by
the way that three officially as of two
weeks ago awesome well done um
as well as my father i was a co-signer
for his truck lunch and i got him to
sell it after him watching me be
debt-free
and that's what i'm calling about my
father's 44 years old
he owns a house along with my mother
he makes about 50 grand a year debt free
now
has no retirement because he's
undocumented
and
not sure what to do because uh morally
speaking you know i've been trying to
get him legalized and do everything the
right way
but he did sacrifice his life and his
home
um to give me a better life here so i
kind of would like to return the favor
and help him out not give him any money
but at least put him in the right
direction
okay
um
i don't know much about immigration law
is there a path for him to go from
undocumented to becoming a citizen
as far as we know we have to petition
and get
people's signatures and do all that jazz
and then get a court case and then he
would have to go back to uh mexico for
about 15 years if it doesn't go serial
but if it does go through then
um it's a done deal but for right now
with all the kovacis going on it's like
on freeze
okay he'd have to go back to mexico for
how long
15 years according to our lawyer if it
doesn't go through
15 years
yes
okay
all right um
and your mom
[Music]
is where
here uh they've both been here for over
22 years
and she's undocumented as well
yes sir unfortunately
okay
all right
um
well i don't know exactly how to tell
you what to do
it seems like the
uh
you know once once you get the other
side of covet i mean there's obviously
it's been 20 years we're not nothing's
on fire here
uh but if you can find a path that is
reasonable
to uh for for them to become citizens i
think that's going to be the mo give
them the most stable life
because they're not having to quote
unquote look over their shoulder all the
time is that a fair thing
uh yeah for sure um i was actually
curious if you know maybe just throwing
money into a mutual fund or you know
something to keep the ball rolling and
at least you know put 800 000 bucks a
month in
and maybe it multiplies over time yeah
obviously he's not filing u.s taxes
right
um
pretty sure he is i mean
when i was a little kid i remember going
to income taxes
and several times they would pay several
times not sure how that works out but i
have heard that i have heard of of a lot
of i mean not a lot but i've heard of
people doing that they pay taxes but
they're not yet american citizens are
not documented what do your mom and dad
think of this have you talked to them
about it i'm guessing because of the
15-year
possibility they're not real keen on the
idea of attempting it or what what are
they saying
so i do have a younger brother he's 11
years old actually he's 12
and they would hate to do that and leave
him behind here i mean this is a great
land of opportunity right uh they love
this country
uh my father plans to stay here forever
my mother would like to retire uh back
back to mexico i haven't spoken that to
them about retirement necessarily i
would like to
almost like surprise and say hey mom and
dad i've done the research i've spoken
to even dave ramsey and chrissy right
here
and um you know how about this you know
i got you debt-free so how about the
next step babysit four yeah
well i guess there's two routes it seems
to me like an or some variation of those
two routes route number one is
that they're able to build wealth in
their name
safely
uh utilizing systems in the u.s like the
roth ira or the 401k or those kinds of
things because you've got a social
security number because you become
linked became legalized okay
that's route one and that has obvious
risks associated and expenses associated
with it that you guys have got to
consider i don't know how that stuff
works okay i'm not i'm not knowledgeable
to it that seems like the cleanest
most stable way
with the exception of the part where the
thing could go sideways and you could
have a real mess on your hands of 15
years or whatever and and and i guess he
could turn around and come back
illegally again i don't know why he
would have to stay 15 years for real uh
but um
uh
i guess i don't know i don't know how
that works but um i'm just thinking on
the tactical side then the other way to
do it obviously is
is less positive for them but that is
they build wealth in your name
and you know you guys pool some money in
the sense that you you you open some
mutual funds that they put the money
into but they're in your name uh and
that way they're safe
uh they're not gonna be confiscated in
some kind of a
uh uh you know an action against them
for being here illegally or something
like that i don't i don't want them to
lose assets that they build right
right and as long as they're
undocumented i'm afraid they could lose
the assets that they build if they're in
their name so i think it'd be wise to
develop a strategy for you to double
down on some of your wealth building but
a section of that being money they
funded and is in your name and i i guess
i would go that way um but that's that's
not optimum um if i can get the risk
lowered
on the process to become
legalized that's going to be their best
route well and emanuel you referred to
your attorney that's been you know
advising you on this
make sure you have a great attorney to
advise you and they should be able to
tell you all the laws all of the
requirements all the boxes you have to
check all the things you have to do to
minimize now it still won't be
non-existent but
minimize that risk of of it not going
through and them having to you know go
back for 15 years so just having someone
in your corner that knows what are they
looking for what are the instances in
which they approve it in the instances
in which they don't and then you guys
just follow everything to the letter if
you decide to pursue that and then
you're going to go through it with more
peace of mind knowing you've done your
homework you've done your due diligence
to follow all the processes etc so
having someone in your corner that is
more knowledgeable than dave and i on
that process is going to be huge it
should be a low bar
well that's valley that's valid
i don't know squad about this
oh
man
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
according to the united states census
bureau nearly 1 in 10 people relocated
to a new city last year and that was in
2020
that means this year there's a good
chance you or someone you know is
planning a move a big move
now i know it feels like there are a
thousand unknowns if you're juggling
when you're relocating but you cannot
lose focus of one of the most important
personal and financial factors in your
move of course that's the house
now always get i always recommend you
get a quality real estate agent like one
of our high octane high protein
endorsed local providers they're ramsey
trusted and they're there to help you
find the right home in your new city
they're top performing experts in their
local market and they've got years of
experience helping folks just like you
so if you want one of our endorsed local
providers they're endorsed they're local
and they will provide you with help go
to ramseysolutions.com
agent and you can talk with a ramsey
trusted agent about how they can help
you with your relocation
ramseysolutions.com
agent our question of the day comes from
blinds.com a great american company with
a 100 satisfaction guarantee
which is weird because it means even if
you mismeasure
if you pick the wrong color if you screw
up their guarantee covers you messing up
they'll remake your window blinds for
free it's an incredible offer incredible
place incredible people incredible
selection free samples free shipping and
new promos all the time always use the
promo code ramsey blinds.com
today's question comes from ashley in
oklahoma i'm an e-commerce seller and
i'm starting to make a very small profit
each month which i'm putting back into
purchasing inventory and shipping
supplies at what point in a side hustle
do you start taking profits out of your
business
well if ashley was here i would love to
ask some follow-up questions um
you know ideally especially with a side
gig if you're starting small and you're
getting scrappy then you want to take
profit out you should have profit
in there as soon as possible because
we're starting on such a small scale
i don't know what up front
major expenses
might have gone into this but this is
something where it makes me question if
she's charging enough if she says i'm
making a very small profit and i can't
think of what the
big expenses up front would be i guess i
just i i don't know i you know i have
some follow-up questions
yeah i'll be selling a lot yeah
and i just want him like does she make
the stuff that she's selling because
that would then affect
you know the time and the profitability
and that type of thing versus just
marking up something that she's
reselling on e-commerce but the rule of
thumb back to the principle the rule of
thumb especially the side gig i love
helping people start small and grow slow
and turn a profit quickly and yes some
of that profit you'll put back into the
business for inventory and equipment
and more business growth and some you'll
take home as your income
i'm always amazed when i'm something
like this i i wonder if we're talking
about a thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars right yeah
yeah so if we're talking about ten
thousand dollars and you call that a
small profit then you need to be taking
some profit out and enjoying it but
if you're talking about the whole
endeavor and you've been working on it
for four months has made a thousand
bucks it doesn't matter yeah
once you do yeah if you took it all out
you wouldn't have anything right
so you've got to get your volume up and
get your uh and or your prices up to get
your mark to get your profits up yeah
whatever it is that's limiting your
profits
so that you have then it and if you're
making ten thousand dollars a month it
doesn't matter then right of course if
you take it out right but if you're
making ten dollars it doesn't matter
yeah
yeah whether you take it out or not so
it's you're not making it you know you
need to solve the
not enough profit
problem then this solves the other issue
then where it goes right yeah right we
need to actually have something if you
take half of very little you got very
little yeah you know and if you got a
whole bunch in there and you take a
little nobody'll notice right i mean you
won't notice it it won't throw off the
business
cycle of your stuff so
um
a lot is solved by increasing your
pricing and your volume yeah yeah
figuring out what that profit margin is
and getting it up so uh and that's a
good rule of thumb for any of you guys
in business so many people i work with
in business
side business small business doesn't
matter they don't know their profit
margin they don't know what they're
actually making
on
the products and services that they're
providing and you've got to know your
numbers because if you don't know your
numbers you don't know what dials to
turn you don't know what to change you
don't know how to improve it
you've got to know what they actually
are well the numbers are telling you
what's working yeah and what's not
working they talk to you yeah if you
listen and if you don't know what they
are you can't you can't listen
dave is with us in san antonio hi dave
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey christy thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
all right my wife wants to build a house
and i would love to do it for her
however i'm a bit hesitant due to the
cost
and i feel like we're in a great
position
if we kind of stay put we can really
start building wealth
so i told her
we we've gotten to go ahead from our
financial advisor
but you know i feel like if i can get
the dave ramsey blessing to move forward
i might be able to kind of
head that direction
i'm so excited to listen to this call
dave dave answer dave's question for him
i can't wait to hear this
or at least you know i'm not crazy for
doing this
um
you you are crazy for letting dave
ramsey or your financial advisor decide
what happens in your life
what you need is principles in your life
that you use by which you make good
decisions for your life
your financial advisor is not your mama
you don't need to ask his permission
what to do with your freaking money
and the same with me
so you you know you
um
you're looking for somebody to bail you
out because you don't want to tell your
wife no
um
but and the two of you need to sit down
together and decide what is best for
your family
i suspect by the way you've couched this
that you got more than enough money to
do this
it's just you don't want to screw with
it and you're and so i think the two of
you need to sit down and say okay here's
what happens if we do it here's what
happens if we don't do it and uh this is
not you taking you giving your
granddaughter a stick of candy this is
you and your wife building a house
and so she's not a little girl
she's a woman and so the two of you need
to sit down with a good vote and she
needs to be a grown-up and go you know
i'd love to build a house but it's not
really best for our finances and i don't
i'm gonna set that aside or you need to
look at it and go
i don't really want to go through the
hassle of this building the house is a
pain in the butt which by the way it is
but uh but it kind of sounds like it
could be an adventure we got the money
without any doubt
mama really wants it and i don't mind
engaging in this process even though
it's not my favorite thing to do because
it's a gift to my wife and and we've got
the money so somewhere in there is your
right answer and i'm not even going to
ask your situation
i'm going to make you make the decision
i'm not going to give you a blessing
it's not my job my blessing to you is
for you to have the tools to make your
own decisions and i think you've got
them
uh but you guys but what you do need to
do i mean what i am going to
bless you to do is for the two of you to
sit down as two adults
not you taking care of some little girl
that wants a stick of candy at the store
that she this is your wife
and um you know there's times that
sharon wants some things and there's
times that dave wants some things and
maybe the other one doesn't care or
maybe the inconvenience is the other one
it's a little outside my comfort zone
but let's go ahead and go that way
and um
you know then there's times that we're
both in complete agreement and there's
times that one of us just doesn't give a
rep you do whatever you want to do i'm
good with it it doesn't bother me and
obviously it matters to you so go do it
and that's an agreement too but we're
making our own decisions with our money
that is not interfering with our future
and our ability to build wealth
and because that then gives us the
options to do the other stuff so it's
really really important that both of you
have a vote well and and have the energy
and care enough both of you by the way
dave to engage in this conversation
because so many people they just want
one person wants to win or one person
doesn't even have the energy to talk
about it so they just let the other
person win
and and you're gonna come to the best
decision for your family when you both
engage and keep working through it if
you don't figure it out in the first
conversation have another one and
another one and another one keep working
through it until you guys come to
something that you both feel good about
and it may take some time and effort to
get there but it's me worth it when you
actually both feel feel seen and valued
in that decision
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions glenn and mandy are with us on
the debt-free stage hey guys how are you
hey we're good welcome where do you guys
live uh buffalo west virginia okay which
is near charleston west virginia yeah
very cool good to have you welcome and
how much debt have you paid off uh 140
000 in four years
awesome way to go and your range of
income during that time uh from 85 000
to 103 000. cool what do y'all do for a
living i'm an engineer
and i have my master's in education but
i actually stay home with my girls oh
good yeah very cool good good for y'all
what kind of debt was the 140 000 uh
that was her house
way to go you guys house and everything
house and everything yep how old are you
guys uh 38 and you have a paid for house
paid for housing you are so weird
i love it how much how much is this
house worth uh probably about 225 now
that's fun very cool that is awesome
very cool congratulations
all right so what happened four years
ago made you decide okay we're knocking
this baby out uh well we've been on the
journey since 2010 actually so we paid
off our consumer debt 2013
from 2013 to 2017.
we did
our oldest daughter has special needs so
we had a lot of
expenses with that
plus we had another baby for our third
child all right and then we did a lot of
things as well so we
went off put our foot off the gas and
slowed down a little bit you were
working four five and six and just
enjoying some of it yeah and then really
in 2017 is when we got more and intense
and decided to pay off the house we had
a goal to pay off by the 40
but now we're 38 so two years before
yeah
cool good
so uh
you started with us back way back in uh
you said 2010 yeah 2010 so uh actually
her dad um gave us the cds
[Music]
about two or three years after we got
married yeah
and so we listened to them i listened to
a lot of them she
yeah i told her about a lot of stuff
and the engineer did the spreadsheets he
did
lots of spreadsheets
yeah so then we went through uh did the
financial piece class
and then got out of consumer debt
and then her big thing was
every dollar really got her yeah going
more oh good okay so how are the
investments going uh pretty good uh
we're probably
over 500 thousand dollars um in
investments for retirements right now
and you said the house is worth three uh
two two okay all right so won't be long
you'll be baby steps millionaires yep
yeah you're on your way wow way to go
you guys thank you yeah probably what
you probably would be 40 years old be
millionaires
yeah hopefully might be the first one in
your family
uh probably not no there's other
millionaires yeah good very good okay
that's good well it's a family tradition
then yeah yes so you didn't inherit any
of this though didn't inherit anything
yeah you just pushed it all the way
through correct way to go so you've been
through financial peace university you
got rid of the consumer debt you decide
you're going to attack the house what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
communication i think
me and him sitting down and doing the
budget every month was really key for me
because i would just be like whatever
just do whatever and he's like no i need
to know what you need
and so we started doing that and the
everydollar app just being able to go in
and see every month and put it in and
that's just what really worked for us
yeah that's good good for you yeah
everybody doesn't love budgeting and one
of the things that's so great about
every dollar and i use this is is it
it's such a beautiful experience it
actually makes it more fun it's kind of
gamified like when you drag and drop
your transactions and you see the
different numbers move so well done you
guys that's awesome that's so so cool
and you're right communication is such a
huge piece of it so many so many aspects
of marriage are affected by
communication and money is a huge one
way to go
glenn it sounds like you did a good job
of pulling her in yeah it was uh
at first it was definitely
me
but
i was going through spreadsheets i would
ask her all the time hey what'd you
spend this on what'd you
and then she's like i can't remember
that was two days ago that was three
days ago
two weeks ago
but once we got on same page later on
and
going through the house is a lot easier
because we were already
past that point and be able to just all
right we're both on the same page yeah
that one chunking on this thing we're
just beating on it knocking it down that
was the big thing for us yeah the last
like six months he had i think seven
different ways we could pay off the
house and i was like just pick one i
don't care just pick one i'm trying to
look at spreadsheets
his hobby is gone now
microsoft excel is one of the best ones
so uh how does it feel to not have a
payment in the world
that's great amazing awesome i mean so
we paid off in may so we've had a few
months now of not having a house payment
it was great going in every dollar and
just deleting that yeah
out of the on the thing so
uh feels very good nothing to do with
103 000 except pay some taxes and enjoy
it exactly and she likes to enjoy it
it's good you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else exactly
that's the big thing yeah well done you
guys that's awesome very well done
so uh you you say the budget is the key
for you
okay
because it's pretty cool to be talking
to 38 year olds with paid for house yeah
that's got to feel kind of accomplished
yeah pretty sure
yeah very neat guys very neat we've got
a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's definitely the next
chapter in your story for sure that you
become baby steps millionaires change
your whole family tree you are well on
your way you'll be there in a couple of
years really with the way your numbers
are stacking up so pretty pretty
incredible that's going to be neat very
good
and uh of course the total money
makeover so you can give that away
because you've been talking about this
to somebody i'm sure yeah and give that
away and get somebody started on their
journey so so proud of you guys thank
you well done heroes
took control of your life and you proved
it can be done oh yeah i think this can
still be done in america today oh yeah
definitely um
in all honesty we've
we tell all everybody about it i mean
that's something how much has changed
our lives
um so we're we're telling people all the
time and so had a lot of cheerleaders
friends that have started with the every
dollar budget and they're like it's just
so free that's right so
we've led financial peace uh
been financial peace coordinators
awesome got people that didn't really
have any didn't have any clue on them
and be able to go through it so wow yeah
very cool well thanks for doing that too
yeah very fun yeah way to go you guys
all right it's glenn and mandy from
buffalo west virginia 140 000 paid off
in four years making 85 to 103. house
and everything they're officially weird
people count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two
[Applause]
[Music]
i one it
man oh man oh man oh man
so i don't know what has shifted but
something shifted in the past
five years um
laura johnson was phone screener on the
show for a long time and uh has moved up
into leadership and our production team
uh and is filling in today for kelly but
laura you can attest to this that uh
it is almost every break when i go out
with with uh at commercial breaks to
meet people in the lobby i meet a baby
steps millionaire somebody who's been
walking this stuff for five or ten years
maybe we've just been doing it long
enough that we're getting to see the
final play of this stuff but the number
of people that have become millionaires
and the number of them at the as they do
their debt-free scream they're also
announcing
oh by the way we're millionaires too
yeah you know because they're they're
you know during their baby steps four
five and six yeah they're you know
they're doing their 15 of their income
and then that paid for house and it
turns into money turns out well it's
amazing i i talked to you about this a
couple weeks ago during a break and i
was like we are getting so many calls
and so many debt-free screams of people
that have paid off their house and it
feels like way more
than we have in the past and i think
you're right i think it's 30 years of
doing this and you're starting to see
the kids of financial peace university
coordinators and people that have worked
the plan and you're starting to see the
the compounding effect of people really
getting serious even earlier in life
paying off their home becoming
millionaires and it's it's it's way more
common now which is really cool we are
normalizing paying off your house and
being a millionaire how cool is that
yeah
yeah we kind of expect you to be a
babysitter millionaire yeah yeah yeah
i kind of knew that with the math all
along yeah but now we're just seeing it
like you're seeing every commercial
break you know i mean they're everywhere
yes it's so inspiring you're right it's
normalized
normalized being a millionaire
that's a cool thing to be known for dave
ramsey doesn't know anything about
investing though i'll just tell you he's
really primitive he doesn't know squat
you don't want to go to dave ramsey for
his investing advice
it's making more millionaires than
anybody else in america this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 28 1
the wicked flee when no one pursues but
the righteous are bold as a lion
[Music]
eleanor roosevelt said a good leader
inspires people to have confidence in
the leader a great leader inspires
people to have confidence
in themselves
james is with us in montgomery alabama
hi james welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey christy how are you doing
today great what's going on
hey um
sorry i'm kind of nervous um you're
great take your time
to set everything up me and my wife are
on baby step two we're about halfway
through and
my stepson graduated high school this
past year and he moved down to where his
grandparents live about an hour away
from us to be closer to the community
college that he wants to go to and he's
looking to study and to become an
electrician
so
he was told that whatever scholarships
he didn't get you know by his
grandparents that they would cover the
rest
and
i guess yesterday my wife told me that
the grandparents only covered half of
what was left over
not including books so my stepson ended
up having to come out of pocket and pay
the difference
and he hasn't come to us and asked for
you know for the for the money or
anything but it's something that kind of
bothered my wife and i guess kind of
weighing on her heart and she wants to
maybe possibly help him out with that
and
you know
i don't feel like he's been exactly
financially responsible through you know
high school and up to this point
he does have a halfway decent job
working with his grandparents they own a
contracting company so he's working with
them you know doing labor and getting
paid for that but i just wanted some
guidance on what you guys think you know
what we could do
what uh how much is he making
working
uh last i was told he makes about 500 a
week and i don't know if that's before
tax or after
and he lives with them for free
i think he has to pay rent i don't know
how much that is
okay
um
and they paid how much and how much did
he have to come out of pocket
my wife told me that he ended up having
to pay about four hundred dollars and i
don't know if that's just the tuition or
if that included books you know i'm
i'm actually on my way home now i was
going to talk to her about it at night
sit down but i wanted to kind of get
your ideas you know first
and how's he going to pay for things
going forward
that's going to be one of my questions
too yeah
really more concerned about that than i
am 400 bucks
yes sir uh because his lack of planning
is going to constantly create a problem
a crisis for other people
yes sir he and one idea i kind of had
was
maybe
you know
if we decide to help him say hey you
know we're going to do this but here's
some stipulations you know maybe go
through financial peace and
you know kind of allow us to help him
work through a budget and maybe kind of
get on track and be financially
responsible so that you know he can
graduate that three because i want the
best for him yeah i i think that's a
really good plan
yeah because here's here's what i heard
okay
um
he didn't have his deal with his
grandparents solidified
it was vague
he heard they were paying for it they
said they would help him
right nobody talked about how much it
was and how much was going to be covered
or uncovered but then when it really got
right down to it
when he found out what the real deal was
because this kid does not play through
details he just kind of wanders along
yes sir
[Laughter]
am i missing something
uh no sir now on my head okay
so
so his lesson his life lesson that he
gets out of this is the way you hit a
goal is you clearly define the goal and
every single step to get the goal and
that's what christy was asking about the
community college and the process there
so yes financial peace university and
yes you map out you have to make two
thousand dollars a month and yes we're
going to know what the grandparents are
paying and yes we're going to lay out a
game plan by which you are going to be
able with your grandparents help to pay
for whatever you need to come out of
pocket and finish this degree and this
is your goal and here's how we're going
to accomplish it and we're going to be
your biggest cheerleaders and we're
going to be your biggest coach and we're
going to make you lay that plan out and
we're going to make you go through
financial peace university in return for
400 bucks
i think that's a great idea yeah he gets
your idea wouldn't mind but um i think
it's a great idea too but the uh but
forcing him because here's the problem
there was no
um this is like building a house without
a blueprints what he just did
right
and he's gonna have to get past that
that's called growing up
but
i'm curious though one one quick thing
james you said he so the the difference
that he that was not paid for by the
grandparents he paid that out of his own
paycheck
uh yes ma'am okay well i just want to
highlight a positive here because he
didn't come to you he didn't ask for
money he paid for it with money that
he's earning so i think that there's
there's i think that's great you didn't
mean like like he didn't come like oh i
didn't plan so please come bail me out
he paid for it so i think that he seems
like the kind of guy that while he may
not be a great planner is receptive to
coaching and direction and so on and so
i think i think that this is going to be
a great plan where you give him some
more tools in his tool belt to be a
better planner to make money go further
i know a lot of college students that
could be like hey bail me out i didn't
know
and he didn't and i think that's cool he
goes i didn't know so i've had to pay
for it
you're right and he still hasn't come to
you but still but he owned it yeah
that's a positive yeah that's a real
positive um yeah he didn't he didn't
show up on your doorstep whining that's
that is a big deal and uh i'd reward him
and compliment him for that and say hey
man i appreciate you manning up but we
want to help you
and uh and we want to help you two ways
one is we want you to help help you with
this planning tool
in your brain we want to insert it in
your brain and coach you along on that
if you allow us to participate in in
that with you we'll show you how to
build that plan out and work it with you
and we'll show you how to execute on it
by going through financial peace
university and then that'll make a ton
of sense carol is with us in
philadelphia hi carol how are you
i'm doing great all day
better than i deserve what's up
okay my question is this um i've worked
for the same person for eight years and
i still have that original
um
salary
i'm not gotten a raise and nor have i
gotten um
i'm sorry it's like a wage
a cost of living
increase that's weird
it's just something that
uh you know should be giving what do you
what do you do
what do i do i'm his
bookkeeper
et cetera and a lot of other little
things how many employees does this guy
have
one you and he's my friend
one and he's your son
yes no yeah he employs me
he's my son
he's a multi-millionaire can easily
afford it
whether you can afford it is not the
point okay i'm sorry who who is your son
your boss
exactly he
hired me to do his bookkeeping and a lot
of other things
you know like i do why have you waited
eight years to talk to your own kid
about a raise that's weird
i do this with other people i expect
people to be mind readers
[Laughter]
thank you for owning that hey we have
made great progress just in your
acknowledgement of this this is this is
fantastic
i do it even with my husband
who would
jump over the moon for me but i want him
to ask me and i i do that around that
that's definitely an issue with me okay
so that's how you ask for the race being
aware of it is a great first step yeah
you go i you know i i thought you could
read my mind son and that i needed to
raise after eight years and you're not
giving me a raise for eight years is
it's been in my mind and you couldn't
see it so i'm gonna put it out here on
the table so now you can see it and it's
kind of ridiculous that you haven't
given me a raise in eight years and you
really need to give me like a huge raise
you're the meanest boss ever
and you're my son please stop being so
mean to your mother
and your only employee
do a better job
you know what it hadn't even occurred to
him no he never has thought about it
she's keeping the books he just assumed
if she wanted some money she would have
said something well she's about to care
you're about to yeah you're going to
walk in there today and go i'm taking
this out of my mind and i'm going to put
it on the table
it's crazy that for eight years i
haven't asked for a raise and it's even
crazier you haven't given one so today's
the day bubba
different way to ask for a raise that
puts the sour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace this is james childs
producer of the ramsay show did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
you